you have been involved in several
corruption cases how much corruption is
there in Israel and how do you fight it
in your own party and in Israel
well you should ask a different question
what's happened to these cases these
cases have uh basically are collapsing
and before our eyes the uh the uh you
know there were uh there was recently a
an event in which the judges the three
judges in in my case called in the
prosecution and said you know your
flagship
the bribery charts so called bribery
charts you know it's gone doesn't exist
before a single a single defense uh uh
witness was called uh and um uh it sort
of tells you that this thing is
evaporating it's quite
astounded even that I have to say was
covered even by the mainstream press uh
in Israel because it's such an
earthquake so uh you know a lot of these
charges are not a lot these charges will
prove to be nothing I always said listen
I stand before the legal process I don't
claim that um uh exempt from it in any
way on the contrary I think the truth
will come out and it's coming out and we
see that not only that but with other
things so I think it's kind of
instructive that you know no no
politician has been more vilified no
none has been put to such a uh you know
what is it about a quarter of a billion
uh
shekels were used to scrutinize me and
scour my bank account sending people to
the Philippines into Mexico into Europe
into America and looking at everybody
using spyware the most advanced spyware
on the planet against my associates
blackmailing Witnesses uh uh
telling them you know think about your
family think about your wife you know
you better tell us what you want all
that is coming out of the trial so I
would say
that most people now are not asking are
no longer asking including my opponents
started trickling in as the as the stuff
comes out people are not saying what did
uh Netanyahu do because he apparently
did nothing
what was done to him is something that
people ask what was done to them what
was done to our democracy what was done
in the attempt to put down somebody who
keeps winning elections despite the
handicaps that I described maybe we can
maybe we can nail them by Framingham and
the one thing I can say about the the
this court trial is that things are
coming out and that's that's very good
just objective things are coming out
changing the picture so I would say
um the the attempt to Brand me uh as
corrupt is falling on its face but the
thing that isn't being uncovered in the
trial such as the use the use of spyware
on a politician
a politician's surroundings to try to
shake them down
in investigations
put them in flea-ridden cells for 21
days invite their 84 year old
mother
to investigations without cause bringing
in their Mistresses in the corridor
shaking them down
that's what people are asking that
corruption is what they want corrected